&gt;&gt; As much as we've talked about Grant, we haven't talked about his actual
product that much. I think it's time that we discuss some of the specifics of
wiper blade engineering. Now in general, Grant aims to have his wiper blades be
exactly 2.5 centimeters long. Please note that this drawing is not to scale.
However, in the manufacturing process things aren't perfect. To acknowledge
that, Grant has created a tolerance range that wiper length is allowed to meet.
As long as the wiper is within 3 millimeters of this total length, either 3
millimeters longer or 3 millimeters shorter, then it's acceptable and can be put
on the market. Let's call the blade length in centimeters of a given wiper x.
What we're really concerned with then, is the difference between x, the blade
length, and 2.5 centimeters, the target blade length. If x is longer than 2.5
centimeters, then you want the difference between x and 2.5 centimeters to be
less than or equal to 0.3 centimeters, which is the same as 3 millimeters.
However if x is shorter than 2.5 centimeters, then you want the difference
between x and 2.5 to be greater than or equal to negative 0.3. Since x could be
something like 2.4, if it's shorter, and 2.4 minus 2.5 is negative 0.1, which is
greater than or equal to negative point 3. Taking into account all the possible
values of x, we want both of these things to be true. So, we need to insert an
and between these two values. If we were to show this range of values for x
minus 2.5 on a number line, you would get this. The region is, just like shown
in our inequalities, symmetric about zero.